Évidemment, ça marche moins bien
que dans les films.
Vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui,
je vous parle de fantômes.
Existent-ils vraiment ? Que dit la science
sur ces étranges phénomènes ?
On prend notre courage à deux mains,
direction l'atelier, qui n'est pas hanté !
C'est bizarre, j'ai
l'impression d'être suivi.
Croyez-vous aux fantômes ?
Si c'est le cas,
vous n'êtes pas la ou le seul.
Selon un sondage datant de 2019, 32%
des Français affirment
croire aux fantômes ou aux esprits.
Et ce n'est pas un phénomène nouveau.
Les histoires de fantômes et d'esprits
circulent depuis
l'Antiquité. Tenez, Homère.
Mais non pas celui-ci ! Homère,
l'auteur grec qui, entre parenthèses,
a hanté tous les cours de latin,
y fait référence dans l'Iliade.
On est bien d'accord,
Homère n'est pas un fantôme.
Quand je dis qu'il hante
les cours de latin, c'est
une façon de parler. Euh... là
tu brouilles les pistes.
Revenons à nos fantômes.
Ils peuvent prendre plusieurs formes.
D'abord, il y a le traditionnel linceul
blanc avec deux trous à la place des yeux.
C'est le plus simple.
Cette représentation
est liée à une ancienne
tradition funéraire datant du Moyen Âge.
Autrefois, la dépouille du défunt
était enveloppée dans un linceul blanc.
Le blanc symbolisait
le calme et la sérénité
avant le passage vers l'autre monde.
Quand l'âme s'élevait,
elle emportait tout à fait
logiquement le linceul.
D'où cette représentation.
Parfois, le fantôme se présente
sous la forme d'une silhouette flottante,
plus ou moins vaporeuse.
Parfois, le revenant se matérialise
sous la forme d'une voix lointaine.
Quelquefois, c'est
un simple courant d'air,
une porte qui claque, un objet qui tombe.
Tu me fiches la trouille là !
Doucement, ça c'est ce que l'on lit dans
les romans et les contes fantastiques ou
ce que l'on voit dans les films.
Personne n'a encore pu prouver
scientifiquement
que les fantômes ou les esprits
existaient vraiment !
Et bien d'autres théories ont été avancées
pour expliquer ce genre de phénomènes.
Ah, tu me rassures.
Tiens, suis-moi,
je vais te donner quelques exemples.
Ce décor : une table
avec parfois un verre au centre,
je suis sûr que ça vous parle.
Il s'agit de l'équipement de base
pour communiquer avec l'au-delà,
autrement dit l'esprit des personnes
qui ne sont plus de ce monde.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le spiritisme.
Au départ, il s'agit d'une blague,
une supercherie montée de toutes pièces
par les soeurs Fox.
Nous sommes en 1848 aux États-Unis.
Maggie et Kate âgées de quatorze et onze
ans, font croire à leur mère
et à une voisine qu'elles peuvent
communiquer avec un esprit
qui leur répond en frappant
plusieurs coups sur une table.
Et les adultes demandent à voir,
enfin à entendre.
Et de fait, l'esprit frappe.
En fait, c'est juste une blague
d'adolescentes, mais avec le bouche
à oreille, le phénomène
soi-disant surnaturel
se répand comme une traînée de poudre.
Six ans plus tard, le spiritisme compte
plus de 3 millions d'adeptes,
Les deux sœurs deviennent
finalement célèbres à travers tout
le pays, communiquant avec les esprits
lors de séances rassemblant
des centaines de personnes,
jusqu'à ce que, 40 ans
plus tard, Maggie
révèle à la presse la supercherie.
En fait, elle utilisait
une pomme attachée à une ficelle
pour provoquer les coups
ainsi que les craquements
de ses articulations.
Malgré cette révélation,
les adeptes refusent de les croire
et rejettent les soeurs Fox,
qui finiront leur vie dans le dénuement.
Les spectres vont également profiter
du progrès technique.
De l'invention de la photographie
notamment. Le photographe
William Mumler prétendait capturer
l'image des revenants
grâce à cette invention, attestant
ainsi de l'existence des fantômes.
C'est en tout cas ce qu'il a fait croire
à de nombreuses personnes à Mary
Todd Lincoln, en particulier, la veuve
d'Abraham Lincoln,
le 16ᵉ président des États-Unis.
Il l'a prise en photo
dans les années 1870.
Regardez. Sur le cliché,
en arrière plan, on devine les contours
d'un personnage qui ressemble à son mari.
Sauf que Abraham Lincoln est mort
assassiné quelques années plus tôt,
en 1865. En fait,
Mumler était un petit malin.
Il a utilisé un trucage souvent mis
en œuvre par la suite au cinéma :
une technique qui consiste à superposer
deux images, en l'occurrence ici
celle du président Lincoln
et une autre de sa femme.
La photographie étant à ses débuts,
tout le monde n'y a vu que du feu,
jusqu'à ce que Mumler finisse
par être démasqué.
Et j'ai trouvé une application qui permet
de faire apparaître des fantômes.
Il est pas mal notre Jamy là ! La technologie
peut engendrer des phénomènes qui,
en toute bonne foi, peuvent faire croire
à la présence d'esprit.
Heureusement, il existe une science
qui est là pour démêler le vrai du faux
et elle porte un joli nom :
la zététique. Zététique.
Et toc les fantômes !
La zététique, c'est
en fait l'art du doute ou l'art
de faire preuve d'esprit critique.
C'est un art bien utile en ce moment
pour débusquer les fake news
sur Internet, par exemple,
et qui s'applique aussi à l'examen
de photos sur lesquelles certains
prétendent qu'un esprit s'est incrusté.
Un exemple concret vous êtes prêts ?
La méthode zététique permet de comprendre
que le point lumineux
qui apparaît à côté de moi
n'est pas un fantôme ou un spectre,
mais qu'il est dû à un phénomène de halo
qu'on appelle un facteur de flare.
C'est en fait une aberration optique
qui est liée à l'orientation
d'une source lumineuse
par rapport à la caméra qui me filme.
En gros, la zététique c'est...
Esprit critique, es-tu là?
Oui. Et parfois, c'est notre cerveau
qui nous joue des tours.
Regardez cette photo,
il s'agit de la planète Mars.
Certains y voient un visage.
Cette photo de la surface de Mars
a été prise le 25 juillet 1976
par la sonde Viking 1.
Et quand on dit Mars, bien évidemment,
on pense aux petits hommes verts.
Du coup, le cerveau
se met à travailler tout seul.
Il interprète, fait des liens entre
ce qu'il observe et ce qu'il connaît.
Du coup, le visage saute aux yeux.
Pourtant, il s'agit simplement d'une
formation rocheuse,
une sorte de butte
comme on en trouve des dizaines sur Mars.
Mais sa forme et la lumière rasante
au dessus donnent vraiment l'impression
de voir un visage humain.
D'ailleurs, depuis, la NASA a pris
plusieurs autres clichés du même site
à plusieurs autres moments qui prouvent
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un visage.
Ce phénomène s'appelle la paréidolie.
De la même manière, en fonction
des circonstances, on va reconnaître
une silhouette dans une forme floue,
un visage dans un nuage de fumée.
Et les exemples sont innombrables.
Impressionnant. Les paréidolies
peuvent également être auditives.
On entend un son et on va chercher
à le rapprocher de ce que l'on connaît.
Le phénomène se produit souvent
quand on écoute une chanson
dans une langue étrangère.
On a parfois l'impression
d'y entendre des phrases en français.
Petite démonstration
avec cette chanson du groupe Scorpions
Still Loving You.
Vous pensez avoir entendu
certaines paroles ?
Eh bien pas du tout.
Voilà ce que dit réellement le chanteur.
Allez, un autre exemple.
Aucun mot de français dans cette histoire.
Il s'agit de l'hymne national russe.
Preuve que notre cerveau
cherche à reconnaître
des sons familiers,
même si ça n'a aucun sens.
Si vous aussi vous avez des exemples
comme celui-ci, n'hésitez pas à me
les envoyer en commentaire.
Parfois, on ne voit
rien et on n'entend rien.
Et pourtant, on ressent quelque chose.
Il ne faut pas sous estimer
la force de la suggestion.
Si je vous assure
que mon atelier est hanté
parce que quelqu'un y a été assassiné,
je vous rassure ce n'est pas le cas.
Eh bien, vous risquez
d'interpréter plus facilement
le moindre son ou mouvement,
comme une manifestation paranormale.
Eh oui, on se fait vite des films.
D'ailleurs, des chercheurs
en ont fait l'expérience dans un théâtre.
Ils ont indiqué à une moitié
des visiteurs que le théâtre
était hanté et l'autre
moitié qu'il était en rénovation.
Ça n'a pas loupé.
Les premiers ont décrit plus de
perceptions étranges que les seconds.
Hallucinant ces histoires.
C'est la magie de notre imagination.
Et les tables et les verres qui bougent,
ça aussi, ça s'explique !?
Oui, et selon la science,
cela s'appelle l'effet idéomoteur.
Ce sont en fait des mouvements
involontaires que nous faisons de manière
complètement inconsciente. Lors
des séances de spiritisme, par exemple,
des participants
qui s'attendent à ce que les esprits
entrent en communication avec eux
pour faire bouger le verre
d'eau sur la planche de Ouija
pour le diriger vers des lettres.
Et tout ça sans s'en rendre compte
et sans le faire exprès.
L'effet idéomoteur est tellement puissant
que les scientifiques estiment
qu'il est capable de déplacer
des tables à l'insu des gens.
A l'origine du mouvement.
Finalement, toutes ces explications
peuvent se combiner
et suffire à créer
de toutes pièces des fantômes.
C'est l'expérience qu'a fait un groupe
de Canadiens dans les années 1970.
Ils ont imaginé un aristocrate anglais
qui serait mort 350 ans plus tôt
et se serait appelé Philippe.
Ils lui ont inventé
toute une vie, puis une mort.
Enfin, les participants se sont rassemblés
une fois par semaine
pour une séance de spiritisme
afin de tenter d'entrer en contact
avec le fantôme de Philippe.
Au bout d'un an,
ça a fini par marcher.
En posant des questions à Philippe,
ils obtenaient des bruits en réponse
et voyait la table bouger,
comme si croire aux fantômes
pouvait suffire à les faire apparaître.
La science et l'esprit critique
ont ainsi pu donner une explication
à de nombreux mystères.
Mais d'autres restent sûrement à élucider.
Chacun est donc libre de penser que la science
y parviendra un jour
ou que c'est la preuve
que les fantômes et les esprits existent.
Toutes ces histoires finissent
par me faire froid dans le dos.
Allez à bientôt les Épicurieuses
et les Épicurieux et n'ayez pas peur.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
abonnez-vous et laissez un pouce bleu.